helping burton was good karma but how
can i get rid of this guy what's the one
thing that could keep him out of the gay
men's chorus
and heist lafuni straight
uh listen it's real cool you'd invite me
over to rehearse well
i'm a giver with no ulterior motive
would you like something to drink maybe
a white wine spritzer
or an american beer in a can that can
crush on your forehead when you're done
drinking it
[Music]
uh no i'm good i just want to get
started yeah
man it would be really cool to go to
europe i almost went once with my
girlfriend
and by girlfriend i mean you know hey
girlfriend what you wearing
[Music]
yeah it was a guy you know huge arms
oh that's a sweet story hug me what
well i feel i feel that we're close now
we shared
oh interesting you gave me the straight
guy double pat on the back no hip
contact huh
actually it was more the gay guy bend at
the waist feel your delts check out your
shoes hug
ah yes how could i have mistaken the two
interesting
um why don't we start with some vocal
exercises
what gym do you go to why haven't i seen
you at the clubs and who have we slept
with in common i work out at home i'm
allergic to smoke and i'm in a long-term
relationship with my high school
boyfriend name ben i know it no you
don't how do you know he told me you
don't
i think i'll have that spritzer now
[Laughter]
jack why is my door locked you better
not be using my hair crimper on your bad
place again
that's a mistake you just make once
excuse me
what are you doing here i'm in the
middle of infotaining
jack i'm not in the mood oh my dog i
have a brilliant idea
i have in my apartment my apartment
in there right now is a hetero posing as
a homo
i need you to help me get proof so you
want me to
in him
forget it okay yeah that's fine
he probably couldn't get him anyway i
mean your flirt's on the fritz
it's no big deal i'll just get somebody
else so you know someone who is actually
sexual
yeah jack that's gonna work if i was
screech i'm saved by them
hey jack can we get started hi
that's him give me a minute to paint on
some cleavage
it's cute right oh
i'm sorry i'm making you uncomfortable
no no no i'm not uncomfortable
i'm gay we love bras right
that is a really really good one i mean
it is awesome
uh i mean it's uh it's fantabulous
well if you like that you're gonna love
the jeans
touch it's okay you know cause you're
gay
right i mean why should you care you
know whoop my hand seems to be traveling
up your thigh towards your uh
rocking ass
but who cares right because i'm gay
so it's all right if i tell you you're
beautiful and throw you down on this
couch and make out with you fiercely
right
yep because you're gay i should be on
top
you know you're a good kisser for a gay
guy and i've kissed a lot of gay guys
[Applause]
got to you six straight bastards
jack get lost i'm not done
good for you you got me but the joke's
on you
i'm still gonna be in that chorus cause
you don't have any proof
exhibit a there's no film in that camera
what do you think i'd be so stupid not
to film my own camera hello
damn you sneaky header rose
that's right your word against mine
buddy but thanks for the help
and thank you for the t and a pushing
and hoping and thinking and praying
planning
and dreaming each night of his charms
that won't get you into his arms
[Music]
that you care
showing that you care just for him
do the things he likes to do
wear your hair just for him
cause you won't get him
thinking and hoping wishing and praying
lying and a cheating tubby and a
tone-deaf
stop it stop it i can't take it anymore
this man
is straight
you